elisa juega un videojuego su personaje
está en la búsqueda para vencer a un
malvado hechicero y sus secuaces su
personaje es un mago cuyos hechizos
tiene un alcance de 6 metros la
ubicación de los objetos en este juego
son almacenados por el programa del
ordenador en términos de coordenadas x y
ahora 5,4 es la ubicación del mago de
lista 87 es la ubicación del secuaz
2 - 1 es la ubicación del secuaces y 90
es la ubicación del secuaz sé lo que me
gustaría que hicieras en este vídeo es
ponerle pausa primero intentar que dado
que el mago tiene un alcance de 6 metros
con los hechizos cuál de estos secuaces
puede el mago alcanzar asumo que ya lo
intentaste entonces solo debemos
recordar que para averiguar cuál de
estos secuaces está al alcance sólo hay
que observar cuál de estos puntos está a
6 metros o 6 unidades de distancia del
mago entonces 6 unidades de 5,4 y para
pensar en esto solo debemos calcular la
distancia que hay entre este punto 5.4
cada uno de estos puntos ahora de esa
manera veremos si la distancia entre
cada uno de estos dos puntos será menor
o mayor a 6 metros supongamos que
tenemos aquí un punto x 1 y 1 y tenemos
otro punto x 2 y 2 cómo calculamos la
distancia entre estos dos puntos bueno
simplemente vamos a usar la fórmula una
fórmula que sale directo del teorema de
pitágoras entonces que nos dice el
teorema de pitágoras el teorema de
pitágoras nos dice que si este lado es
el cambio en jr de hecho lo voy a poner
en valor absoluto así que el cambio en
ye y digamos que este lado es igual al
valor absoluto del cambio en x el
teorema de pitágoras nos dice que la
hipotenusa será igual a la raíz cuadrada
de la suma de los cuadrados de los dos
lados entonces tenemos el cambio en x al
cuadrado más
el cambio en al cuadrado y el valor
absoluto lo dejo un lado porque esto
está elevado al cuadrado entonces será
positiva la respuesta así que en
realidad lo que debo hacer es averiguar
entre estos dos puntos cuál es el cambio
en y cuál es el cambio en x elevarlos al
cuadrado sumarlos y tomar la raíz
cuadrada de la suma así que hagamos esto
entonces por ejemplo encontremos
encontremos el la distancia entre los
primeros dos puntos de hecho voy a
nombrar a cada uno de estos puntos este
será p 1 este será p 2
este será p 3 este p 4 entonces vamos a
encontrar la distancia entre los
primeros dos puntos a la distancia entre
p1 y p2 distancia entre p1 y p2 esa
distancia es igual a la raíz cuadrada
del cambio en x al cuadrado pero quién
es el cambio en x el cambio en x es 3
así que 3 al cuadrado es igual a 9 ahora
9 más cambio en yale
cambio al cuadrado también es 3 entonces
tenemos 9 aquí raíz cuadrada de 18 eso
es lo mismo que 3 x raíz de 2 esto de
aquí es menor o mayor que 6 veamos
3 por 2 es igual a 6 y raíz de 2 es un
número menor que 2 es 1 punto algo no no
sé muy bien pero sí sé que es menor que
2 entonces esto de aquí es menor que 6
ajá y eso nos dice que pedos si está al
alcance del hechizo del mago de elisa el
mago del isa puede atacar al secuaz y
muy bien entonces ahora pensemos en el
secuaz ve la distancia de p1 ap3
entonces distancia de 1 a 3 será igual a
la raíz cuadrada del cambio en x al
cuadrado el cambio en x es igual a 3
negativo pero 3 negativo elevado al
cuadrado es igual a 9 positivo ahora
esto más el cambio y al cuadrado el
cambio es igual a menos 5 pero menos 5
al cuadrado es igual a 25 tenemos la
raíz cuadrada de 9
25 esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de
34 esto es mayor o menor que 6 veamos
tenemos que la raíz sabemos sabemos más
bien que la raíz de 36 es igual a 6 y
esto es menor que raíz de 36 así que
esto es menor que 6 este secuaz b
también está al alcance de un hechizo
del mago de elisa ahora pensemos en el
último secuaces entonces la distancia de
p1 ap-4 esto la distancia de p1 ap-4
será igual a la raíz cuadrada del cambio
en x al cuadrado pero el cambio en x es
igual a 4 y 4 elevado al cuadrado es
igual a 16 más el cambio en que al
cuadrado pero el cambio en gel al
cuadrado es igual a menos 4 menos 4
elevado al cuadrado es igual a 16
tenemos raíz cuadrada de 32 y la raíz
cuadrada de 32 es menor que raíz
cuadrada de 36 que es igual a 6 entonces
también esto es menor que 6 entonces
podemos ver que el mago
alcanza a todos los secuaces todos están
al alcance a una distancia menor que
seis unidades de él pero cuál de éstos
es el más alejado bueno esto lo podemos
simplificar esto es lo mismo que raíz
cuadrada de 18 que es claramente el
menor de los tres cierto por lo tanto el
secuaz a es el más cercano al mago al
hechizo del mago este es el más cercano
mientras que el secuaz b es el más
alejado y bueno ya resolvimos este
misterio espero te hayas divertido nos
vemos